if you've been a close follower of this
channel for a while now or even of the
scp foundation archive as a whole then
there's a pretty high chance that you
might have heard of scp-096
even if this just so happens to be the
first of rscp videos that you've ever
clicked on you still might have seen the
shy guy itself in various other corners
of the internet since the earliest days
of the scp foundation
scp-096 has gradually become one of the
most iconic and recognizable creatures
in the foundation's entire menagerie of
anomalous beings despite standing taller
than any ordinary person you might be
forgiven for mistaking scp-096 for a
human being if you were to see it at a
distance but the creature is unusually
proportioned to say the least still
appearing almost human in its shape but
possessing long dangling arms that
almost reach the ground
scp-096's body is thin and hairless with
opaque clear white pupillus eyes and a
wide gaping mouth or so we've heard
thanks to drawings provided by someone
who sadly isn't with us anymore but you
might be surprised to learn that scp-096
doesn't really do all that much mostly
the tall spindly humanoid spends its
days walking mindlessly pacing around in
its containment cell sounds like most
days in a college dorm during lockdown
right that is of course until someone
dares to look at
scp-096's face it doesn't have to be
directly either it can be something as
simple as glancing at a photo or
watching a video of the creature but the
moment it is seen the exact second it is
perceived the wiry monster will know
having its face viewed in any way will
cause the shy guy to really live up to
its nickname the creature suffers some
sort of psychological meltdown covering
its face with its huge claw-like hands
and weeping
scp-096 quickly becomes utterly
inconsolable
suffering from extreme emotional
distress until it simply can't take it
anymore pulling itself up to its full
looming height
scp-096 will stand and travel at
impossible speeds towards the person
that dared look at its face there's no
way to hide from the shy guy nothing can
stand in its path as it tracks down this
unlucky person and when it finds them
well it's certainly not pleasant somehow
without leaving any trace on their body
scp-096 will kill the person that looked
at it possibly even eating them
afterwards then it calms itself down
returns to its more docile state and is
typically bagged and brought back home
by whatever mobile task force is closest
scp-096 has killed many of the teams
sent to contain it proving itself to be
resistant to gunfire and any forms of
conventional weaponry as much as being
only a tiny speck in a photograph that
is enough to trigger the creature's
relentless defense mechanism nobody can
get away from it either there is
literally nowhere in the entire world
that someone can run to escape
scp-096 not even crossing the oceans or
jumping aboard a plane is enough to stop
it and if our community questions video
on the matter is anything to go by you
may not even be safe in outer space the
scp foundation's only real way to keep
the creature safely under wraps and
contained is to lock it up and force all
members of personnel to never ever look
at it while they hunt down any pieces of
recorded media still out there waiting
like a ticking time bomb so if no member
of the foundation can look at scp-096
how do they interact with it well
luckily there's a tale that answers
exactly that known as a lesson in power
dr danielle kowalski a member of the
foundation's research team assigned to
scp-096 was sent into the creature's
cell wearing a sleep mask you know the
kind you get on expensive flights what
she was really wishing for though was a
gas mask to go with it nobody had warned
her how bad
scp-096 smelled then again few had been
as close to the creature as she had and
lived to tell the tale as a child
danielle kowalski had a fear of stepping
into the ocean her mother used to warn
her about treading on a stingray and
dying as a result giving her a phobia
that stayed with her for many years but
danielle's father had encouraged her to
face her fear to shuffle her feet on the
ocean floor kicking up sand so that the
stingray would know she was coming and
would simply just swim away perhaps if
he could have seen what kind of horrors
danielle was working with at the
foundation her father wouldn't have
tried to make her so fearless maybe
there are some things that it's logical
to be afraid of entering scp-096's cell
dr kowalski could hear the monster's
heaving breaths the perfect mix between
a frightened whimper and a death rattle
the haunting sound of a person's final
gasp of air in the back of her mind
danielle hoped she didn't touch the
creature by accident the closer she got
the tension and the heat of its warm
breath against her skin was making the
approach all the more terrifying she had
been issued with an instant camera and
took a photo in the dark click the flash
fired but with her eyes covered she
couldn't tell that was good though that
was the point if danielle could see the
flash going off she could see what else
was in the room and that would put her
in even more danger she was locked in
with a kind of stingray that wouldn't
swim away even if it knew she was there
slowly dr kowalski began blindly
photographing the cell around her
stuffing each freshly printed photo into
her pocket as the camera spat them out
over the span of 45 minutes she took a
series of pictures of the entire cell
until the film and the instant camera
had run out danielle knew that she would
probably only need one picture but
better to have more just in case luckily
none of her foundation colleagues were
around to tell her how insane what she
was doing actually was they were all
preoccupied preparing the site for its
first official visit from the fbi this
all took place after what was known as
the broken masquerade had taken place
essentially knowledge of the scp
foundation and its research into the
endless stream of anomalies it had
contained was all made public people
knew the truth now and the foundation
found itself in the one place it never
wanted to be the public eye the
organization and its activities were
under the scrutiny of every journalist
on the planet and once more information
about the scps and the anomalous world
of the foundation became known the world
would surely change forever
danielle kowalski knew all of this and
told herself that everyone would need
something for protection now she only
hoped her photographs would be enough
fifteen months later dr kowalski was
interrogated in her apartment by one
agent o'brien he and a group of fellow
agents had barged into danielle's home
demanding to know the location where a
number of scp-610 specimens were being
held scp-610 being of course the
infamous infection known as the flesh
that hates a disease capable of turning
human beings into horrible deformed
monstrosities of flesh agent o'brien and
presumably whoever he was working for
was intent on turning these creatures
into weapons and the man had little
patience for a former foundation
researcher who wasn't giving up the
answers that he wanted danielle tried to
argue with the agent citing the berlin
accords against weaponized anomalies a
motion proposed to the united states
senate that would forbid the use of
anomalous objects entities and creatures
as weapons for any country o'brien
wasn't interested he claimed that if the
kremlin in russia had no intention of
ratifying such a law then america
wouldn't either the agent had his men
grab danielle by her arm while he
grabbed her right middle finger and
began to push a thin knife under her
fingernail the former member of the
foundation tried to stifle her screen
but couldn't stop herself as the pain
struck as agent o'brien tortured
danielle he told her that the russians
had all the information they would need
about scp-610
in order to turn the flesh into some
kind of weapon as far as he was
concerned the united states government
needed access to those scp-610 specimens
to know exactly what they would be up
against in the likely event that russia
used the flesh that hates against them
and only a researcher for the scp
foundation the former senior researcher
on the scp-610 project would know where
to find those specimens you don't think
it's reasonable for the united states
government to want to understand what
could be used against us o'brien asked
as danielle's blood trickled out of her
finger into his leather gloves
hell i don't care what you think we're
gonna do with it i want those specimens
when the agent finally let her go dr
kowalski tried to catch her breath
forcing herself not to scream in pain
again she pointed with her other
unharmed hand to her bedroom telling
o'brien to check the bottom left drawer
she had placed a manila envelope in
there containing the only thing danielle
had kept since departing the scp
foundation under o'brien's orders his
man ransacked the nearby room and were
quickly able to find what they were
looking for the envelope was presented
to agent o'brien who was no doubt
expecting to find a file inside
something that detailed the exact
location of those specimens he was
looking for so you can probably imagine
the dissatisfied look on his face when
he opened the envelope to find
photographs a collection of instant
photos all taken in a dark cell with all
of them depicting a tall thin humanoid
creature a being with long dangling arms
that almost reached the ground a thin
hairless body opaque pupillous eyes and
a wide gaping mouth furious to once
again be denied the information he was
looking for o'brien disregarded the
pictures and burned dr kowalski's neck
with his cigarette in his anger he said
i think your foundation sure thought
they were powerful hiding in the shadows
but i'd like to explain to you why
you're wrong the agent then went on to
describe his time as a member of the dea
in the late 1980s and how he'd been
involved in the hunting of notorious
cartel boss pablo escobar i had a narco
in custody every bit as uncooperative as
you are now the man had insisted that
escobar owned all the colombian law
enforcement but a younger o'brien had
argued that if that was the case and
they possessed all this power then why
did pablo escobar's men hide their guns
why smuggle drugs in secret and bury
their money where no one would find it
if they really had the control they
claimed much like escobar's cartel the
scp foundation had always moved in the
shadows a power that o'brien believed to
have really belonged to the government
your anomalies belong to us your
research belongs to us your life belongs
to us he told dr kowalski suddenly one
of the other agents noticed movement
outside of the apartment the second that
danielle saw a long arm face through her
wall with gray skin like that of a
corpse she snapped her eyes shut o'brien
and his men drew all their guns and
opened fire on the monster that had
walked through the wall as if it wasn't
even there all the while danielle
kowalski kept her eyes shut the sounds
of screaming and snapping bones and a
sickening slurping noise filled the air
but she made sure not to look within a
few quick moments of panic and agonizing
pain it was over the apartment was quiet
apart from strange breathing like a mix
of a frightening whimper and a death
rattle run along now zero nine six dr
kowalski told the shy guy there are
worse monsters in this world than you
now go check out
scp-096 shy guy escape incident
096-1-a containment breach and scp-096
look at a picture of shy guy in space
the shy guy questions and theories for
more on everyone's favorite homicidal
introvert